[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down the best season for
fan theories for Westworld it's been one
week since the show ended and there's
still a lot of things up in the air
there were some big deaths crazy
cliffhangers and overall there's a lot
to discuss in terms of what could be
happening here we're going to be going
through how we know Stubbs is alive what
could be going on with William the
secret part that could be getting
explored what the time jump means and a
lot more there will obviously be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the full season yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the content before we get into the video
I just wanna let you know that this
breakdown has been sponsored by raid
shadow legends it's a game that I'm sure
you've seen advertised multiple times
before and it's for a good reason
I've left a download link in the
description below if you want to go
check it out and it really is the
perfect thing to play right now enter
the epic world of ttle area where dark
elves meet the sacred order and the
banner lords are in an endless war with
the undead hordes collect equip train
and upgrade your team of heroes in order
to start the journey of a lifetime raid
shadow legends will take you to the
world of dark fantasy and realism and
it's free to play and is available for
both mobile and PC what I love about the
game is it's got a whole host of RPG
elements to keep you constantly playing
and the game has six story lines so
there's plenty of content for you to
blast your way through challenge
yourself to the edge in the ongoing
tournaments compete against the entire
raid community while fighting the
spiders then ice golems peak the
almighty finite or the notorious dragon
patch 1.5 is coming in May and with it
you'll be able to compete in the brand
new arena tournament in points according
to your tier and win some amazing
rewards in the local and global
tournament as a thank you to fans of the
channel if you go to the video
description and click on the special
links all new players will get two
hundred thousand silver and one free
champion tree fella these are available
for the next 30 days so make sure you
quick I'll see you over there good luck
okay so we know that at some point
Westworld will be having a major time
jump this was teased at the end of the
second season in which we saw William
return to the forge showrunners Lisa
join Jonathan Nolan confirmed that this
was taking place in the far distant
future once the world had ended and thus
it was theorized that Williams Ark had
been taking place in a complete
simulation of the park in which the
events played out exactly the same as
how they had with the host uprising
it seemed that William was a host and
that they were testing for fidelity to
see if the Dallas immortality program
had been achieved there's been a lot of
speculation about this over the last two
years however the end of the third
season seemed to provide some answers in
that we saw William had been duplicated
by hey Loras who was in the process of
creating a host army Williams seemingly
died - and in the fan community many
have gone back and forth over whether
the character is actually dead or not
personally I don't think that he is and
I believe that the way that the show
runners would have handled his death if
this was the case would be a lot more
dramatic William has been one of the big
bads in the show since its inception and
the same guy like that I think would be
disappointing we didn't see the
character take his last breath and
therefore I don't think that this is the
last we'll see of him as we saw from
Caleb pretty much all wounds can be
healed if the person is not dead and
though I don't think that he will be
storming out the gates in season 4 Nolan
enjoy another they can always bring him
back should they need to it would be
great to see him going head-to-head with
the host once more and taking them down
would really bring everything full
circle having more William versus
William fights would be an interesting
aspect of this show in terms of duality
we would have to Williams both having to
decide whether what they're doing is the
right thing and as we know neither
copies would mind smacking the other out
with the steel chair though this may not
happen what will happen is that us fans
will no doubt continue to question what
the hell was going on in the credit
scene of season 2 it is possible that
the William we saw was the copy and this
would explain how the character was able
to live far into the future if it was an
exact duplication it would to mean that
the host would carry across his
existential crisis and nurse it would be
unable to fully grasp reality perhaps it
will be revealed in the end that this
host was the one react
we saw through season one and two merely
going through a simulation that mirrored
the events of the host uprising and his
journey to the forge was purely to test
fidelity this will explain how in season
three we just randomly caught up with
William back at his house even though we
didn't really see how he got there
it would also tie into the time jumps
that we've seen throughout the series
making us once more questioned
everything that we've seen this ties
further into the overall arc of the show
and where I think things will be going
for season four the replication of
humanity was seen in Hales lab in the
house making part of Dallas Dubai and
it's clear that this is the direction
and they're going for the future in
season two we learned that Dallas had
the data on four million people and hey
will have a huge army to pull from so
going ahead it appears as if hail will
be the antagonist for season four it is
possible that this was actually all part
of the plan carried out by Solomon and
on reddit user full-time 2017 dropped a
great theory about the AI god
they say that Solomon had likely planned
this all now in order to turn humanity
into hosts we did see through a whole
bomb that should the plan that Solomon
set out come true that the human race
could be extinct within as little as
fifty years did give a time range but
yeah things aren't looking good for us
why this may be the case is because that
humans may have been fully replaced by
hosts at this point especially with Hale
working double-time in the basement of
Dallas HQ Solomon was trying to get a
grip on humanity in order to control
them so that it could save the species
from itself it is possible let's plan
this entire time was to put us on a path
that would see us all turned into hosts
so that it could place us on our own
loops hosts can be controlled and guided
far easier than humans can and the
ability to program them would pretty
much remove the need to take away the
outliers
perhaps humans becoming hosts is
inevitable and we've already seen from
Williams work on James Dallas that the
key to immortality always lay within
transferring a consciousness to them so
hails uprising may be a foregone
conclusion now that she has an army and
she will likely be able to take our
humanity far easier in the upcoming war
but who exactly will fight in this well
we do know that that already exists an
army of outliers and deep freeze at
re-education Center in Mexico Caleb the
news
of humanity knows of these and he will
likely have to throw them out to fight
in the upcoming battle as they've been
kept out of the loop as it were their
data will not be present at Delos so
hail will not be able to replicate or
use their brain scans to predict how
they will act we saw that house William
was able to copy the real one perfectly
and if Hale doesn't have this as a
weapon against them then they could get
the upper hand now Aaron Paul has
already signed on for a fourth season so
we know he will be returning but
actually think he will be teaming up
with an unlikely ally that is Ciroc
Ciroc was left alive at the end of
season three and I think his final few
words actually hen had the direction he
will be going in the future
the character was left screaming at
Rehoboam to answer him and eventually
this turned into pleas for his brother
he could end up returning to the
outliers with Caleb in order to free
them to stop the incoming war she on me
would be far more trusting of his own
kin than he would some stranger so I do
think that he will be needed further
down the line after thinking about it
and knowing what we do have serac I
think that John me schizophrenia
actually showed us a lot of things about
the character in episode 8 of season 3
will learn that serac was completely
obeying Rehoboam and is possible as
shown me schizophrenia was because he
refused to obey all of the time he had a
voice in his head constantly whispering
things telling him what to do but when
he went against this this caused
complications that led to his psychosis
and questioning a right and wrong a
still thing that there's a lot to
explore with both the serac brothers and
season 4 will likely bring them back in
a new light in addition to this the fate
of Dolores still hangs over the show
though we saw her completely wiped at
the end of season 3 and heaven Rachel
would confirm that that would be the
last we saw of this version of Dolores
that doesn't mean she's gone for good
having already confirmed to Jimmy Kimmel
that the character would be returning
for the 4th season though she did not
know in what capacity there still exist
several Dolores pills out there though
and they could easily be placed into the
shell of the one that still hooked up to
Rehoboam you also still have Lawrence
Musashi
and of course Hale who all contain
Dolores personalities the main reason
for Hales fall was because she had
difficulty not being in her own body so
it could be possible that the key to
defeating
her lies with putting her back into a
Delores shell either way Delores has
died countless times before so I doubt
that this is the last we've seen of the
character another character that we've
likely not seen the last of his Stubbs
at the end of season 3 he was left in a
bathtub bleeding out and though this
likely spelled doom for the character
there are hints that he survived before
entering the sublime a Bernard placed
the briefcase and gun on the bed beside
him and journeyed into the host heaven
however when he awoke there was no gun
on the bed beside him hinting at Stubbs
getting out of there and taking it for
protection now we don't know why he
didn't come back but the fact that Mae
didn't check in on the motel room and
Stubbs never returned shows that
something big has happened in the world
this would explain why no one has
stopped by to rescue him and it's likely
that the apocalypse has already happened
Bernard journey to the sublime to find
out what to do once the world ends and
he may have been successful merely
sitting in hibernation and waiting for
it to all blow over I think that by the
fourth season we will likely operate
with three different timelines and
realities and the first will show the
war being fought by Caleb the second
will show Bernards journey to the
sublime and the third will be after the
war and it will focus on possibly
William and Bernard Nolan recently told
The Hollywood Reporter that Bernard and
William are now in two separate
timelines so that could lead to a fourth
one for the fourth season but we will
have to see if everything comes full
circle it makes more sense to me with
both characters being in the future but
only time will tell
and finally is Maeve who is still on the
hunt for her daughter as we know she is
in the sublime and after Maeve's mission
in season 3 which was to track down the
key to the forge it does seem likely
that she will still be searching for
Bernard however as we know from the
flash-forward she never finds him to me
this teases that there will be a return
to the park and that she will enter the
sublime the old-fashioned way the Dallas
web site was recently updated to show a
complete shutdown of all their
facilities there are some notable little
teasers was actually an advertisement
for a brand new park that is completely
obscured now shoutouts write it for him
blurring this image and pointing out
that it was a castle in France this is
of course medieval world at which we saw
teas throughout the second episode of
season 3 and now
we haven't actually seen the park itself
we do know it exists
reddit also managed to and scramble some
of the text on the website and it does
look like that it will indeed contain
dragons so who knows we may get to see
may go back to west world and even get
to see how this park operates as she
navigates the landscape of Delos I think
that the only way for her to fully
reconnect with her daughter is through
this manner and I can't wait to see how
it's handled going ahead and that's
pretty much all of the fan theories that
I have for the fourth season but I'll
make sure to keep you up-to-date with
any news on the show going ahead 20:22
seems like a long time away but I have
no doubt we will have teasers and
trailers before then that let us know
what we're in for
so hopefully you stick around for a
coverage of other things obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on these
theories and if you have any of your own
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of how we would have liked
to have seen the season end which is
gonna be like that too this if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month and please click the
join button below you want to chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey
or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this month
II can win the marvel face repot one box
set and all you have to do is comment on
a video and make sure you sub with
notifications on the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of May and
the set will be shipped out from then -
ever gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you